[Music]
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
look at that look at that
look at that look at that
he's smarter than you why who thinks
he's smarter than you why is smarter
than you
this is
look at that
look at that look at that batman's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shock man
[Music]
this is
is
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship debanking
harass
at that look at tyranny corporate tank
over censorship d-banking arrest tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that corporate
takeover censorship d-banking arrest
tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser he's a disgrace
and he's a disgrace
and he's a disgrace and he's a disgrace
look at that look at that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
[Music]
big massive dump the faucet on in areas
where there's tremendous amounts of
water where the water rushes out to sea
because
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to once
gums dumps dumpsters
[Music]
what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
seems like a pretty good deal a bag of
mangoes mango aren't mangoes like three
seeds
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
[Music]
bring my mango
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mangoes
fortunately affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy don't want me to be healthy if
highway
[Music]
well i was all set for it to be really a
very special evening and i hate to have
to start with something other than good
news but unfortunately i've just
received notice via super chat on
youtube that one of our long time
viewers papi
got coveted today
and says i got covered david is your day
any better
well
i didn't get coveted that i'm aware of
uh but i could be i could have it and be
asymptomatic but that is not good news
that's not good news papi and we're
hoping it's a mild case very very mild
as mild as can be
we are in florence south carolina here
awaiting some kind of a
in february we were calling them febrile
screeds
um
i think in march maybe we would call
them
delusional denumons uh i'm not sure
we're gonna come up with something for
uh for for this month but we're waiting
for a speech from donald trump scheduled
for just about 50 minutes from now right
side broadcasting is on the ground
um newsmax is on the on the ground they
even sent eric balling
over there
uh so a lot of different things are
happening here and it's even uh
we it's it's sort of i guess being
called a 2022 rally
in so far as trump is here to endorse
someone i mean i mean we'll find out who
i don't even know
um it's conceivable that donald trump
will announce some kind of
space exploration initiative the united
states will be the first nation to land
an astronaut on mars he may announce the
colonization of countries we've never
even heard of mexico
he may make a declaration in terms of
the banning of certain genders and we
will ban men
and uh
he may make some kind of um
[Music]
some kind of other weird statement hold
on i'm coming right so we
anything could happen tonight
absolutely anything could happen tonight
um and we will be
standing by
for it
as the kids these days say
i want to say thanks to robot laser
party as well as bagel tv
for the twitch prime subs thanks guys i
really appreciate that i have so many
different things to go over um i do have
voicemails and we may we may get to some
of them
uh
some of you yeah some of you may notice
that we are getting dangerously close to
90 000 twitch followers now let me see
i'm gonna try to do the math here
if we're trying to get to a hundred
thousand followers on twitch and we get
to 90 000 okay let me see if i can do
this
9 divided by 10 is 0.9
0 divided by 0 is 0.
0 divided by 0 is 0. 0 divided by 0 0
that's 92 percent of the way there right
if we have 90 000 we would be 92 percent
of the way to a hundred thousand is that
right
can anyone check that math or is it
eighty-eight percent
i'm not even sure damn
i it's it's gonna get very close that i
think is i think is the point
um okay
yeah let's not even let's not even start
there okay i've got a couple quick
different things and then we're going to
get to some videos from the um oh oh oh
oh no so this is what i i have so many
different things i wasn't even sure
where i wanted to go next so one of the
questions today is whether donald trump
will set a new record for lies per
second
now my assertion is and you guys can
tell me if this doesn't sound right
the record for lies per second was set
by donald trump
uh just a few days ago where he told
four lies in 12 seconds now you might
say well hold on a second sir this
segment is 17 seconds that you're about
to play that's right but ronna mcdaniel
is talking for the first five and in 12
seconds trump lies four times i think
this is the the fastest lie rate i've
ever seen take a look see if you can
spot them for me dur and you saved
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
lives with that well you know we had in
1917
100 million people died i think we would
have had the same thing so we did
something that was incredible we did it
in less than nine months and it was
supposed to take anywhere from five to
12 years
so did you guys catch the four lies
there that's four lies in 12 seconds
the first lie was that there was a
pandemic in 1917 i mean there wasn't
the pandemic was in 1918.
the second lie was that
there were without the vaccines 100
million people would have died that's
not a serious estimate i've ever seen
the third lie is that
it it should have taken five to 10 12
years to develop an mrna vaccine of
course no the whole point of mrna
technology is you can get the vaccine
done in like a year
and then the fourth lies that trump
developed the vaccines or did anything
materially significant to that so you
guys know those are all lies so we don't
we don't have to worry about that too
much um other super chats coming in dale
earnhardt says sir zero mangoes divided
by zero mangoes leaves no mangoes
actually the answer is kiwi
kiwi
thanks to gregory blueberry babe
anir ben bagucci
the hobo
coloring to smile independent and enter
patman
who have just uh subscribed via twitch
prime very much appreciate that thank
you very very much um
okay
uh here tell me what you guys think
about this here's a guy who was kicked
off of a i believe that this is delta
he was wearing an f biden hoodie and
regularly taking his mask off and he was
asked to leave because he was not
wearing his mask and the airline i guess
doesn't allow profanity
because it's a family airline
let's take a look at this
now why aren't we hearing it
did i mute the tab
tab's not muted
and stick to public security okay and if
you don't
come on the jet bridge flip the shirt in
outside in and out right so that word
doesn't show i will not discipline the
whole aircraft
i'm sorry about that so it's just delta
policy you cannot wear it
and they did advise me also you will be
in the no flying list
okay
so you want to come on in the jet bridge
let's just keep the shirt and get
everybody else too willy
yeah you have to show me something all
right it's a policy and you can call and
we could go ahead and look it up online
right on the jetpack the computer
because last time i checked i lived in
the united states of america with the
person freedom of christ
i love when he i love that when people
go i
wasn't isn't it is this still the united
states of america i love that i last i
checked this was still the united states
of america this is an airline sir
what does the first amendment have to do
with it these are freedom religions
do i not have the freedom of press or
freedom of religion or freedom of speech
anymore in this country is he saying
criminal speech oh freedom of speech i'm
like what's he talking about criminal
religion [ __ ] he's saying freedom of i
see it's something very simple it's not
simple it's not simple my dad serves the
united states no
no my dad served in the military so i
got the freedoms today and now you're
telling me i have to take off my hoodie
i don't understand how a carriage
contract between a private business and
a customer has anything to do with what
his dad did in the military you know i
mean like hey great his dad served
that's fantastic i'm not taking anything
away from his dad i just don't see how
that entitles him to
unilaterally make changes to a carriage
contract with an airline
wow
so i'm still getting kicked off the
plane yeah you're not putting you're not
wearing the mask
i literally just took off my hoodie
that's the funny thing the masks also
been off the entire rant if you actually
nice i will come back and ask which i
was doing and she came back why does she
have to ask nicely for the mask to go on
when you get your ticket now it tells
you five times you've got you when you
buy the ticket when you check in
when you it's it's when you go through
security you're you're told about why
does she have to be nice for you to put
the mask on
all right as you can see that i'm
relating the message to you what the
captain says i said he doesn't want to
up the aircraft
okay so okay what's your name brother
john l brooks
yeah so currently delta airlines is
kicking me off for
i mean i worried my max the last time in
the whole fight
on a different flight guys i mean listen
he wore his mask on a different flight
the whole time
why
why does he have to wear it now this
this is sort of like
listen uh
with my last girlfriend i wore a condom
i i need to wear one now too
what what is wrong with these people
last flight i wore my masks
really have to commend the flight
attendant i have to tell you i mean
really keeping keeping her cool and
wow okay so that that happened and uh
yeah i'm flying on thursday i'm hoping
for no incidents no incidents whatsoever
via super chat hey david which of
trump's verbal crutches do you find most
annoying i find them all funny i don't
know that i find any of them annoying i
mean they're all basically indications
that he's lying like when trump says
that they came to me and someone called
me sir sir sure that means he's lying
when he says and it's really a shame
that means he's lying when he says many
people don't realize that
it's a lie when he says and and uh what
what's the other one
and it and and we can never let it
happen again that's also a sign that
it's a lie we can never let it happen
again obama gave the biggest crime and
we can never let it happen again well
what that means that means it didn't
happen you should look up on twitter the
funniest two minutes in television
history the exchange between an indian
host and his guests is hilarious i don't
know how i would search for that indian
host
larry says chapter 23 xrl or 52b pound
trump speaks blacks for trump's listen
and then tune out
through history wow larry i love you i
don't know what you're talking about
there
do i have trumps trying to say indian
cities no they weren't indian cities it
was trump trying to say
the names of indian cricket players
and i need that on my sound board i
don't think i have that
oh that is a key
no i don't have that
that's a that would be a good clip
no that's a good one um yeah that's
that's a really really good one that's a
good one
uh let's see what else we got here david
i saw a girl on the street in copenhagen
wearing a pacman hat we love wait oh
that is fantastic you know that's that's
beautiful last time i was in denmark
a really nice guy
i was biking in denmark
well obviously in denmark you bike they
have the absolute fantastic uh you know
um uh bike lanes and all these different
things i was biking and a guy bikes by
skids to a stop and goes david pakman
i believe his name was morton
and we chatted for a little bit and took
a picture together it's actually on my
instagram this was years ago this was
years ago
um
okay
good
uh let's continue if we can
what else did i have oh i have a few
different elements from the rally here's
something really funny trump is without
a doubt the most dishonest president
we've ever had in terms of just number
of lies lou holtz at the rally earlier
he's like a college football coach
talking about how when trump says
something you know it's true reasons why
i supported president trump before he
ever had the nomination
number one i trusted him we told you
something he meant it he said that's
complete lie everybody met and he meant
what he said
he promised that what everything he said
he would do he did so that's also
completely untrue he didn't build the
wall he didn't do the new health care
plan he didn't do any of the things he
said he would do i trust him completely
when he said something taking the aback
the second thing
he wants this country to be great he
wants us to be the best that they could
possibly be
and everything he does is committed
excellence you look at every decision he
made wasn't to help him personally was
to help this country that's completely
wrong trump's decisions are all to help
himself
and the last thing about him and i
believe is after spending a lot of time
with him
he cares
he cares about the people in this
country that's an also an absolute lie
he cares only about what people can do
for him only what people can do for him
doesn't care at all doesn't care at all
about other people if we learned
anything it's trump cared about people
only for as long as they were donating
to him
david sir has destiny confessed to the
crime of meme jacking obama yet obama he
has not
how many people is he going to claim are
at the rally oh that's another thing we
should do some kind of a of a
uh
not a money bet but you know how you can
wage your points and stuff
at trump's last rally
he erratically claimed that there were
87 000 people there
and uh we've we estimated there were
like five to eight thousand
um
how many people will he claim are at
tonight's rally that's a really good
question
i don't know the answer
i don't know the answer
i was referencing the insane chapter
number system for the blacks for trump
oh yeah yeah yeah blacks for trump let
me see if i can pull that up i still
don't even know like to access the
blacks for trump website it's like not
even indexed in google you have to know
like a very very esoteric
um
url
in order to even find it i've never
there's never been a website it's almost
like it's on the dark web
except it's not
um
i i can't even find it i can't even find
it guys
uh okay let's see what else happened
here's a guy on a scooter of sorts on
what are those called
with a trump one flag
at today's rally
here's gigi the greek goddess who
believes communism is here
watching your channel
gigi
this the greek goddess say that
communism is here because the
us the american people allowed allowed
to bring communism to this country
they're allowing it to come in this
country we're not raising it right
and we're allowed their people they're
not on the same page about exactly how
is it entered how communism has entered
these two people are in agreement that
it is here
but
gosh darn it they're not on the same
page about how it got here people the
americans not to stand up and fight
for our country the beautiful country of
ours
and yes they stole our elections
the big tech
soros the democrats the republicans the
demon
uh did this is uh this is hitting all of
the um important talking points for
these people oh they stole elections
swamp needs to go up right now this one
do we think is that a greek accent do we
think that's a greek accent it's sort of
sounding like one to me not an expert in
accents i love your shirt there you go
turn around oh
all right there you go it's okay don't
be the same baby because the guy that
guy he is more than that
he needs to be in jail for treason all
of them
every everybody uh mike pillow wants to
eliminate all machines and this woman
wants to put every all of them everybody
needs to be in jail man that is really
something else
um
here is the trump endorsed candidate to
go against nancy mace
she says she has four priorities if
she's elected let's that that that's
gotta be
fascinating people are low country first
things we need to do when we get up
there fire fouchy
fire fouchy
second thing get rid of the department
of federal education
oh man third thing start impeaching
biden and open huntington biden's laptop
open it up guys and now when do you
think when she says open the laptop does
she mean flip open the lid or does she
mean
like take it apart
i don't even know what i guess it's more
of an i.t question than anything else
um
[Music]
okay so that's everything there
uh we've got some patriot take stuff let
me make sure we're not missing anything
no we're still good see what else we've
got here
i arrived four days early for a trump
rally
good morning trump will be here in the
field behind me in four days that's
gotta be satire right that can't
possibly be real
that can't possibly be real they arrived
before it was even staged
joe and the hoe gotta go oh so it's just
oh okay i see
it used to be thinly veiled misogyny now
it's just open misogyny i guess against
kamala harris
so there's that
um oof it is not looking like the
conditions are favorable there guys
man
we'll have to be watching that
i'm having a trump-themed wedding woman
is at the rally
uh here's a guy
with the melania cardboard cutout
wow
wow
oof it's it's going to be a it's going
to be a wild night guys it really is um
i don't even know
this is uh it's insane what's going on
thank you to avalanche of spinach
beth graham
rhapsody's on grass
raging heart
on
hamathurg's
cf goss
for the twitch prime subscriptions
appreciate that guys that's putting us
at number 15. very very much appreciate
your support
uh david sir what do you think of the
increase in the price of gas will do to
the price of a bag of mangoes well i
expect if the mangoes come by truck
i expect that um
the price of mangoes will go up if the
price of gas goes up this is it's my
instinct it's my instinct let's do a
couple voicemails as we uh as we
anxiously await
the start of the rally
let's see what we've got
here is uh here's whitney chiming in
so i want to share this article it's how
vladimir putin's childhood is affecting
us all
in 1994 former president jimmy carter
proposed establishing okay she actually
reads the article for a long time here's
troy york david pakman um your president
uh joe biden continues to lie he's no
more my president than troy's i mean we
both live here it doesn't matter whether
you voted for him or not he's he's he's
the president
and you never make any videos addressing
his life
and he continues to say that government
spending has nothing to do with
inflation when in fact that is a lie
a democrat you know it
i am not going to take an economics
lesson from troy york
who calls in barely conscious most days
i'm just not going to do it guys it's
just not happening
um guy with the weird phone connection
calls in
i think peter ducey has just proven
through his stubborn refusal to listen
to what gensake told him on the on the
question of keystone right she explained
that it's not an oil field it's a method
of conveyance very much so very much so
whitney calling in again
there's this little blonde woman running
for president and
um
it's just like weird how she had people
do like the me too movement because i i
don't agree with putting these girls
putting all their information on the
internet where it's like somebody could
find them and hurt them
and there's a lot of people that just
don't care that just want to like reel
in the heart and
you know whitney i i still i still have
no idea what on earth you're talking
about um i did want to look at a couple
of tucker carlson clips tucker carlson
is really working hard
to um somehow try to defend what
vladimir putin is doing and most
recently on his program uh last night he
spread
debunked conspiracy theories about
ukraine that probably doesn't surprise
too many of you last night we told you
that the buy demonstration is funding a
number of secretive bio labs in ukraine
now that's a lie labs that are
conducting experiments on highly
dangerous pathogens yeah so the us has
worked with ukrainian labs
on public health research as they have
with so many different countries uh the
idea that the u.s is funding funding
dangerous secret ukrainian bio labs is
simply not true it's not a story as we
told you we wanted to do well it was a
lie so you shouldn't have done it in
fact we didn't think it could be true
and it's not yeah so over the top and
bizarre in any case the administration
had repeatedly and very aggressively
denied that they were doing anything
like this i think what tucker says is
how is ukraine allowed to have
scientists
um
yeah so as the new york times explains
carlson is conflating ukrainian
biodefense labs with biological weapons
facilities ukraine has the former it
does not have the latter
and then they attacked anyone who asked
questions about it as a tool of russia
we foolishly assume that in this one
instance they might be telling the truth
last
it's an insane show
um
let's continue in fact the us embassy in
kiev has acknowledged joint american and
ukrainian research on other passage
pathogens such as hemorrhagic fever
virus apparently there's a lot of this
going on in ukraine funded by the united
states did you know that there's a lot
of this going on all over the place
remember guys it's like you know at a
certain point you think these people
will be like
there were labs in china researching
stuff
and there's labs in ukraine researching
stuff in this case the labs in ukraine
don't have anything to do with the
russian invasion
it's almost like
there's labs all over the world
researching stuff and sometimes the us
partners with other countries and
research is done
wow
wow
then of course um
tucker brings on glenn greenwald who he
described as an expert in detecting
deception what does that even mean
here's a little bit of glenn greenwald
who i mean has gone dangerously off the
rails last question maybe you don't know
the answer but why ukraine you know of
all the countries you would conduct this
kind of research in you would pick one
with like a solid they didn't pick one
see this is like this is the problem
they didn't pick one just because he's
only talking about ukraine because
ukraine's in the news
nobody picked ukraine
in fact
for a year or two the problem was we
were doing research in china with
chinese labs remember
nobody picked ukraine
medical infrastructure you'd pick
germany or israel or some place with you
know first-class scientific research
going on which is being done
why ukraine
unless you viewed russia as your primary
threat as unless you wanted to be
provocative toward the russians unless
you wanted to man this is this is like
very serious brain rot very very serious
brain rot in ukraine developing all
sorts of weapons as we clearly have been
we've been flooding that country with
lethal arms first so
we've provided it's true we've provided
ukraine with weapons trump tried not to
because he wanted dirt but then thanks
to vinman trump ended up having to
every one of these statements is either
deceptive
or lacks context or is a lie
now he's confused we've given we have
given ukraine weapons and you can be
against that it's okay to be against
that but to say that that has anything
to do with
research labs that don't make weapons
it's it's it's really something for five
or six years so clearly there's an
intention for the united states to be
heavily involved in ukraine the russians
say their motive is to be threatening
and provocative the united states denies
that but they have their tentacles in
ukraine and have for many years all the
time which is a critical part of the
narrative that has been lacking that's
right it's fair if you watch this stuff
you would come away thinking
all sorts of things are taking place
that are not taking place
um
carlson then pivoted to wrestling with
straw men who want the u.s to start
world war three but the only example of
a pro-no-fly zone elected official is a
republican yeah
one person calling for a no-fly zone
immediately became increased calls for a
no-fly zone
it's not the only suffering in the world
the suffering in ukraine are real some
of them are incredibly heart-wrenching
it's not the only suffering in the world
but it's it's real suffering
the argument from people limited people
like maria salazar is well people are
suffering we have to commit arms you've
been in a conflict firsthand does our
committing arms necessarily relieve the
suffering on the ground that's their
assumption is it true
no no not whatsoever no and of course
that's not even really the argument i
mean
it's just none of this makes sense guys
none of this makes sense let's listen to
the situation in florence south carolina
even the milk boys record setting
interview with me was taken down because
i told the truth okay so that she's
reading a trump statement and the news
max is in a commercial right now okay
all right fair we're gonna continue we
have plenty of things to do
thanks to dave sykes for the twitch
prime subscription number 16 today
really appreciate that
uh the hand says with a very generous
super chat after millions of americans
not understanding basic science with
covet and the rise of fascism with trump
i'm disappointed in our democracy and
afraid of the rights tyranny feeling
lost where do i go from here we're all
trying to figure out the answer to that
we're all trying to figure out the
answer to that i don't know where we go
from here
exactly right says you say tucker's
lying about biolab weapons but you don't
actually know that you're not privy to
classified information talking out of
your ass yeah but exactly right that
that's a very it's it's quite frankly a
very ignorant thing to say
that's like saying if i come on the show
and i go listen thanks for the five
dollars by the way yeah it's very
extreme ignorance if i come on the show
and i go listen um fox imagine fox news
was claiming that uh let me let me come
up with a game imagine fox news was
claiming
that
joe biden was involved in supporting
uh
um forced child labor
in minds in ecuador
okay like imagine that that was that fox
news was reporting that
uh on on an opinion program you know
without citing any actual sources
and i said to you guys yeah that's
that's that's just not true there's no
there's no evidence of that
you can always go you haven't been to
every square mile of ecuador you can't
be sure of that right but we don't have
any evidence of that we have no evidence
for what tucker is saying
do most people understand that like yes
of course anything could be going on but
tucker has no reason tucker has no
evidence that it is going on
and if you claim something is taking
place the burden of proof is on you
you understand exactly right is not
exactly right it's not on me
to search out for evidence disproving
there's just no evidence that supports
that
if you're claiming something you have to
provide the proof
come on guys give me a break
larry quarter which says it redirects
for from blacksfortrump2020.com
blocksfortrump2020.com
yeah you guys have to see this this is
the website for blacks for trump
and it has um
so at the top you've got pages okay
um michael says i am the conservative's
answer to black lives matter you can get
uh some kind of app
this is where it starts getting crazy
it just reads so this is section dd
then this is section one or one dot cc
depending on your preference
then it goes to one cc two
one a
one and we found
we found one okay
really easy to follow then we get two
okay now it's making sense two a
three
four
five or zero section zero
six or double zero
seven
eight or triple zero anyway you uh it's
it's sort of the um it's the it's the
website navigation equivalent
of those conspiracy boards with
everything linked together with red
string you guys know what i'm talking
about
it's the uh
it's the equivalent of that
um
nosco says could media literacy slash
logic and schools as a policy be framed
in a way that's palatable to
conservatives like a bill to teach
students how to think not what to think
i think that that's a really good idea
actually
i think that's a good idea
uh the right has very aggressively
pulled slash prevented slash dumbed down
critical thinking and media literacy in
schools
uh because they correctly identify that
when people think critically they don't
vote for them
um
there might be some way to frame it so
that they might like it yeah i like that
idea
i want to say a massive thank you to
mark english mark has just signed up on
my website joinpacman.com
and his new member number number 17
today i really appreciate that mark
thank you so so so much we're standing
by here for donald trump just moments
away assuming he's on time he is
unlikely to be more than a couple hours
late he did have some kind of an
airplane issue the other day
and um i don't totally know what
happened but i guess he's now wants
people to give him money to get a new
plane
let's see trump airplane
engine issue
let's see what exactly what happened
trump plane made emergency landing after
weekend speech to gop donors
the plane was in the air between 20 and
30 minutes before an engine failed an
engine failure is not like a small thing
um
two people plane was in the air 20 to 30
minutes an engine failed the pilot of
the private plane decided to turn around
and go back to new orleans the plane was
on route to palm beach where trump
resides at mar-a-lago
the landing was described as emergency
in nature
someone else disputed that the word
emergency was used
the rnc scrambled and reached out to a
donor and found trump a different plane
oh my god and trump didn't get back till
3 a.m
amazing trump i love this
trump delivered a rambling 90-minute
speech before donor saturday where he
spoke on a range of topics
he uh jokingly suggested the us bombed
the [ __ ] out of russia with planes
bearing the chinese flag wow
that's quite an idea
china yeah
adam schiff a watermelon head
george conaway a son of a [ __ ] trump
also this is beyond parody trump said he
was looking very very strongly at the
possibility of waging a 2024 comeback
bid for the president isn't that the
best looking at that very strongly
it's uh it's it's a parody of itself it
really is
man
he's looking at it super strongly
um
fire tucker and hire jimmy from philly
there's an idea
remy buckler my best advice is zoom out
and anything you cannot directly affect
you got to listen but then acknowledge
your limitations and let it go you're
doing your best yeah that's stoic
philosophy okay stoic philosophy
suggests dividing
phenomena into two categories those over
which i have control and those of which
i don't have control now the truth is
with most things it's
i have some control
you know
things over which i have total control
things over which i have no control and
things over over which i have some
control so like the great example of
that middle category would be
imagine that
you have a tennis match coming up
you don't have control over who wins
because there's another player
but you also have control over how you
train you have control over your
attitude going into the match you have
control over your practice regimen you
have control over your diet you know etc
so this this idea from remy is it's
right out of that stoic philosophy of
divide things up into i have total
control no control or some control
and um
that's that's what it is and i could can
be very very useful
um let's see what else we got so close
they should have landed much faster yeah
some people some people wanted trump to
die in that plane in the plane emergency
the other day there are people i would
never wish that on anybody
i want to say thank you to alex hempel
alex just signed up on my website using
the coupon code obama obama and his new
member number 18.
um
also thanks to asf clops and gordon z
hall
for the twitch prime subscription thank
you guys let's listen to the sights and
sounds in florence south carolina where
we were moments away from donald trump a
georgia person brian probably want to be
focused on texas but south carolina also
is a really important state i
have to pull out the article but
it's incisive political analysis and
newsmax still not uh not at the venue
yet but they
they will we will will be rather they
will be
uh welcome okay so let's i see there's
people here now who have not uh who
don't know what's going on welcome to
everybody watching on twitch
facebook and of course youtube
tonight donald trump is holding a rally
to quote save america
in florence south carolina some say
florence some say florence there are
many brainwashed cultists at the rally
but that is not unusual what is
different about this rally is that it's
at least in theory a 2022 rally where
trump is endorsing and promoting some
candidates
you'll see them later we looked at some
clips from them earlier they're all
extremist lunatics who
we would be very very uh sad to see
become
elected officials in the united states
and that's what we're anticipating here
tonight and we are just moments away
from the rally
do you think trump might announce his
run today
i think trump is going to wait a very
long time because if he announces that
he's running it changes a whole bunch of
financial reporting and use of funds
requirements and he's admitted he
doesn't want it he doesn't want to be
limited by that
mark english says why is he still doing
rallies he's not running he's not
president it makes no sense unless he's
running a con for money oh so again yeah
he's running he's raising money for his
pack and endorsing 2022 candidates
that's what he's doing
that's the point of the rally to the
extent that there's any point to any of
this
that's the point
make of it what you will my friends make
of it what you will let's listen to a
couple other voicemails
and see what we've got
uh basically david pakman you on your
video
peter gucci and jenn kosaki you lied
like 20 times
um all you do is lie right
you accuse trump a line
while you july joe biden has had an
agenda and stated before the election
did he say that joe biden has angina
that's a heart condition right i didn't
think that that was the case
angina
um
whitney checking in about jesus
oh so when i looked up like jesus was
typed like
as if he was
something like the moon
um
so
what i'm getting out of like this
picture like the whole picture it all
lines up to like
jesus being like
his moon has like an eclipse
so it's like something that happens like
every once in a while and then i looked
up eclipse it's also the infj which is
typed as jesus um for this
music band called jesus like the moon is
not something i've heard before
mr pacman uh you have joined the ranks
of the vile and disgusting people
who you decry and um
call out by name
in yesterday's show march 3rd
you did a
ridiculous thing because you pander to
your supportive paying audience
when you asked
what do you think how long is this war
going to last in ukraine
it's called engaging with my audience
what does that mean
it's not pandering to say what do you
guys think it's
wow you know there are shows where there
is no audience involvement at all right
there are shows out there like mine
where
you don't get people calling in
you don't get super chats you don't get
voicemails they don't show emails they
don't show comments
my whole thing was
this all really only exists because of
the audience like without the audience
it's just a guy in a room with a
microphone and it's sad it's extremely
sad
so that's why i allow the audience to
participate and sometimes it's horrible
i mean look at you know half these
voicemails and
70 of the calls i get i get it
but it's not pandering to allow the
audience to give their opinion
it's kind of like the whole point of the
show it's a very weird thing
hawkeye heyoka with tonight's
um uh biggest super chat
50 david sir enjoyed your interview with
alexandra hudson great points about the
difference between politeness and
civility two things right when
right-wing radicals fail at consistently
thank you hawkeye i really appreciate
that generous contribution
john says even though these rallies are
a clown show it's keeping the republican
base fired up and engaged while the
democrats are just adrift at sea 100
100
thank you to james welsh for signing up
for a membership
uh new member number 21 today at
joinpackman.com also thanks to punk on a
bike punk on a bike with the twitch
prime subscription very much appreciate
that let's do a couple other voicemails
let's see what else we've got
um here's another another uh incisive
commentary from whitney
so i don't understand
is
why is it said that like women are just
as nasty as men
and then they say men are in control
well which is it
are men the nasty [ __ ] ones
or are they in control
because they can't be both
you can't say i'm in control but you're
the nasty one
when it's like
okay well you said that you're like the
leader
so everything's your fault right but
they'll say everything's women's fault
and then take all the glory like they
did everything good right when it's like
why would anyone do anything bad
intentionally
these are really
pretty big philosophical topics from
whitney here and uh i think it's gonna
be we're gonna need more time to really
think that through i don't know that i'm
even equipped to
kind of parse that out as it's powerful
commentary very powerful commentator
commentary
thank you to christina hedger christina
just signed up
on my website and his new member number
23 appreciate that very much thank you
um
yeah let's uh let's listen as we await
donald trump here see some movement some
cars moving but
i can confirm
that 45
is in that white tent
can confirm imagine calling him 45.
that's really something else let's see
how newsmax is teasing the the rally
sirens were on you mentioned that before
that turns into a yeah it turns to an
active law enforcement kind of event
when the former president is actually
there on the ground on the ground all
right so for most of the last two
decades some of our past presidents have
shown a dangerous lack of seriousness
when dealing with vladimir putin or
maybe he's just
yeah i can't even take that i can't even
deal with that right now i can't even
take that seriously right now
ken asks a good question
will there be a trump library and if so
what will they put in there i guess just
crayons and porn magazines right i mean
i don't know what else you need in there
hard to imagine
i want to say thanks to eric emmert who
just signed up on my website
joinpakman.com thank you eric welcome um
listen let's do a little something just
because we're getting very very close to
the rally okay
uh we're all having a great time and all
of that but i do need to ask you guys
for just one favor i need 11 000 votes
give me a break not that not that this
is a completely legal favor not one for
which i should be imprisoned
indefinitely uh we actually do depend on
your support to fund our program the
podcast the tv show everything we do
grab a membership on my website that's
my request go to joinpakman.com
we have a coupon code up there sad trump
because these trump screeds have really
become quite
sad at the end of the day hold on i'm
coming whoa easy donald wait well hold
on i'm still talking about membership
here uh so what you can do is you go to
joinpakman.com
you can do monthly or yearly i suggest
yearly but some people like to do
monthly okay and the coupon code goes in
the coupon code field sad trump
and if typed correctly
it does something unbelievable look at
that i'm not even gonna say this number
out loud because what from what i
understand in south carolina this
discount's not even legal
okay so i would love it if you signed up
at joinpakman.com and i will thank every
single one of you every single one of
you and extra bonus see how we're at 24.
whoever's number 25
gets a free david pakman show coffee mug
i will send it anywhere in the world
that has
delivery right like i don't think i
could send it to north korea i don't
know what happens to mail sent to north
korea there's probably some parts of
very remote countries i couldn't get it
to but if the mail service goes there we
will whoever is the next person number
25 at joinpakman.com
free coffee mug going out
okay
dave you often refer to snl in the
context of things being beyond parody
with the disclaimer that you don't find
it funny anymore i'm the same age at you
as you what do you think was the funny
era of saturday night live
uh
oh man i i
i'm not like really a historian or an
historian of saturday night live so i
don't want to be super
definitive about oh hold on a second
they're interviewing trump before he
takes a stage here in florence south
carolina now mr president i have spent
hours
donald trump rally
the american people are angry they're
angry what's going on in our country and
particularly sweaty and disheveled today
and the spray tan couldn't possibly be
worse look at that bright white ear
compared to this very strange amber face
so it should have never happened in a
million years this wouldn't have
happened
putin just did what he wanted to do he
would not have done it with us you
understand that most people they do
polls on it and this was something that
was not going to happen
or it would have happened in four years
four years nothing you know a lot of
people are saying how come this didn't
take place during the four years that
trump was there a lot of people you can
say the same thing with china because
that'll be next with taiwan
uh it's it's a very soft situation
i think what happened with afghanistan
and the way we withdrew not that we
withdrew but the way we went through it
looked like a surrender
left 85 billion dollars worth of record
nobody understands what that means 85
billion it's like
the entire backdrop just shook did you
guys see that the flags are like shaking
dead soldiers just incredible brave 13
but you know we also had many that were
horribly horribly wounded nobody
mentions that we left american citizens
behind
i think that the afghanistan move the
borders are horrible inflation's
horrible it's all bad
afghanistan move was the single most
embarrassing moment in the history of
our country
you look at the uh
middle class the lower class uh they are
basically stronger prices and gasoline
uh that needs to be reversed as well
yeah well it's uh
gasoline now we were at a dollar 87
and now i see where even like in the
midwest it's at five dollars okay you
know we always use california as a guide
because they seem to be hired now
they're almost up to eight dollars
uh it's not even thinkable and we're
going and negotiating they want to
negotiate with venezuela and iran can
you imagine and opec but venezuela and
iran
it's not even thinking it's not even
believable it's almost like
you know where are we living this is not
the world of reality here we are we're
fighting venezuela fighting iran and
this guy wants to go and make a deal and
the one place he doesn't want to take it
is
right under our feet now it's going to
be used in our country so why wouldn't
we take it right but it's uh they just
don't know what they're doing final
question mr president our viewers want
to know how's the family how's melania
how's the family the family he hasn't
spoken to her in years we love this
country but it's never been i don't
believe it's ever been so low as it is
right now and a year and a half ago we
had the strongest borders the best
economy we had everything was perfect
and now you look at it we rebuilt our
military but they left 85 billion for
the taliban
but
it's very embarrassing we're no longer a
respected country we have leaders that
are not respected
but we can turn it around and we'll make
america great again that's all i can
tell you we'll have to do it and we have
the midterms coming up and then you have
the big presidential election the last
one was rigged we did better the second
time
that we did the first we got one and you
go well you know you lost the second
time
we may have to do it again so we're
going to see what happens but uh we love
our country we're going to save our
country god bless thank you president
trump thanks for your time thank you sir
thank you sir that they actually did
call them sir okay small fuzzy moss has
been able but yeah the the the physical
appearance of trump is
degrading badly um small fuzzy moths
just got me my clips of trump
mispronounced pronouncing indian names
those are genius
that's the best huh
[Applause]
namaste
namaste
everybody namaste
exactly my favorite i think is still
this one swami vive
that's too much
man that is too much
uh
wow
okay
um i want to congratulate new member
number 25 today who has just won himself
a free david pakman show mug
and that is greg quimby number 25
signing up on
joinpackman.com with today's coupon code
sad trump now that's not all i promised
everybody gets a thank you
i want to say thank you to the following
people who just got memberships and are
really just great people zoe adams
i'm going to do my best with all these
pronunciations bryson hall
jeremy laprade
james peterson
cameron turner is a new member
andre masado
john and martha shepard
marcus gillard thank you
maxwell newell and brett lutz okay
that's 10 so that puts us at 35. let's
see if we can keep the numbers straight
stephen borba
casey smith is a new member
alexander laminin
david annetti
oh boy here we go
now
i'm about to say quite frankly i'm about
to sound like trump swami vive
joel
maheri joel i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly that puts us at 42.
um joshua mcconey
bradley woods
frederick milton
dave mergenthaler
jf stephen crockett very much appreciate
that putting us at 48.
naftali gachiriri
oh god i i'm doing the trump thing
aren't i
[Music]
robert elliott okay robert elliott i
feel good about pear lindstrand
sounds scandinavian
grant kissel
jamie campbell
dom hassett
laura glissman and barry belicky
puts us at 58
and lastly
william bishop iii
james dyson
and joel bowles
numbers 59 60 and 61.
very oh no and these are these are
pouring in thanks to jen johnson and
tyler reeves number 62 and 63.
we are just moments away here folks
moments away
of course i'm not forgetting forgetting
about the people watching on twitch
uh blueberry onions fips and papa bear
kenzo
submitting twitch prime
um okay so the snl thing i really liked
i would call it the
is it maybe the early 2000s when snl was
like really funny
early 2000s i think
um i mean obviously you know people like
phil hartman but i think that was even
earlier than that
uh
mid-90s
there was a pretty long period where snl
was was genuinely good but i'd have to
go back
one of my um this isn't this isn't snl
but one of the the funniest tv moments i
mean if you you know i'm talking about
something somebody just really really
funny
one of the funniest tv moments that i
recall and every time i watch this i
just find it so funny
it's when chris farley was on letterman
and he entered like this now i we know
he had trouble with drugs this is sort
of like a coked up insane situation but
this is the best
[Applause]
just the energy is just crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
now this had to be staged right he
wouldn't really take a random guy and
put him in the trash can and also the
guy stays in the trash can for a while i
have to assume this was staged
[Music]
and i think he cartwheels here yeah
[Music]
uh and honestly one of the funniest
touches is letterman asking are you all
right and it's like sadly no here's
pillow let's listen to pillow these
policies that biden has put in place
well yeah and we will first we gotta
remember we gotta fix 2020 and we're
well on our way
machines will be gone it's gonna be a
beautiful i see a future that's
beautiful it is a beautiful future all
machines will be gone i had to put my
toaster and my espresso machine my
beloved breville i had to put it into
the witness protection program today
because pillows coming for all machines
you know that's what he's here today
going all these rallies now to get
candidates that have the people's back
candidates for one and you see uh people
are looking for hope look at i mean this
crowd just been cold it was rainy this
morning
he is slurring up a storm he is he is a
slur fest tonight huh when mike lindell
walks on stage here
[Applause]
because everybody
they're awesome
they are awesome well they're awesome
because because
you've given them hope in the election
you know god gave me a platform with a
big mouth right and uh and that is the
hope is spreading the hope
that because we do have all the people
can anybody be like this
without stimulants at his age i mean
it's a serious i'm being serious thing
and we have judges now that are getting
brave we even have some news outlets
that i i have a hard time doing that
actually had somebody on talking about
election crime i think they might have
even said to me no they didn't say yeah
yeah
they haven't got that far yet he's
completely shot out of a cannon here
real quickly to the video let's see if
we can get that real quick
we'll double box
people want to know there's hope you're
telling us right now if you want yeah
this is not the guy to tell you that
there's that there's hope geez
that chris farley clip was a perfect
segue into mike pillow i know it's it's
almost the same thing that it's actually
stunning that we just looked at
chris farley and now we're looking at
this i want to make sure i thank
everybody who's signing up today because
there are so many beautiful people
being extremely generous today dave
wallen
stephen hill is a new member welcome to
aaron levith and sebastian bloom
cynthia elise smith and pasquina gabriel
thank you thank you thank you putting us
at 72
also over on twitch bilisk
uh yeah i don't know that's that's
probably the wrong pronunciation but
you're definitely number 73 here as we
await donald trump for everybody
oh hang on a second let's step aside
let's see where we're going
[Music]
they're doing the song and everything
yeah
let's see maybe uh i guess they're maybe
newsmax won't cover it huh
[Music]
[Music]
a particularly disheveled and confused
looking donald trump as
something very strange seems to be going
on i don't know if that emergency
airplane landing a few days ago
uh
[Music]
has stopped him from eating but looking
almost straight he's he's still heavy
but he's almost gaunt gaunt and heavy
it's a very unusual thing and going a
little heavy on the spray tan and it's
just it's all looking really really
really weird uh i don't i don't
totally know what to what to make of it
really
did you get the mic pillow sound clips
i don't have any mic pillow sound clips
but that would be a great library to
have actually
that would be really really good
um
let's see what else we've got going on
here
[Music]
[Applause]
anybody think he'll finally lay out that
health care plan that he promised in
august of 2019 do we remember when it
was two weeks away in august of 2019
anybody think we're gonna get that plan
tonight maybe possible
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah um i do want to say thanks to extra
lee i appreciate everybody who's been
signing up uh we we will be carrying
trump uninterrupted momentarily of
course of course
um and we'll keep super chats up on the
screen
as trump uh speaks i would prefer the
new okay let's go over to the news max
feed president trump they they drive
from hundreds of miles to hear his words
and let's hear what he has to say let's
see how he talks about ukraine tonight
and see kind of a waste of time to drive
i mean he said the same thing for years
about every topic let's listen in here's
the president
he may announce today his taxes are no
longer being audited so he's going to
release him oh what a crowd this is it's
freezing out here
it's freezing out here
but we're gonna warm it up we're gonna
warm it up
hello to south carolina what a place
what a victory we have
hold on i'm coming
nobody told me it was so cold in south
carolina i always think of warm
beautiful sun
but this is gonna keep us awake his eyes
seem almost completely swollen shut i
want to thank
everybody for being here it's incredible
i heard you went through rainstorms and
everything else and
you're freezing your asses off and
this crowd is unbelievable thank you
thank you
you know i just wish the fake news would
take those cameras look at all of them
they just showed the crowd
they never do it they never do it they
don't like to do it
it's funny it's first of all they're
doing it and also the only k the only
networks covering these rallies anymore
are right-wing networks it's newsmax and
rsbn best vote count isn't that nice we
had an honest vote count with thousands
of proud
hard-working american patriots that's
what you are
eight months from now the people of
south carolina are going to vote to fire
the radical democrats you're going to
elect an incredible slate
of true america first republicans you're
going to
reelect your governor henry mcmaster
and together we're going to end nancy
pelosi's political career once and for
all
and we will ban men for the past year
we've watched in horror
do you think joe biden touches kara into
a calamity and a total disaster
it's one train wreck after another he
abolished our southern border have you
ever seen anything like it
millions and millions of people
many of them from jails from other
countries are being dumped into our
country
he invited him in he invited her in he
does nothing about it he triggered
massive inflation
there were more
deaths in 2021 than all of 2020
and hospitalization shattered every
record even well by when does the ldf
biden illegal mandates all over the
place
he ordered the department of justice to
spy on patriotic parents he crippled
american energy
he disgraced our nation with his
humiliating surrender in afghanistan
there's never been a lower point in the
history of our country
there's never been a lower point in the
history of our country
dead soldiers left our
people behind
85
billion dollars worth of equipment left
behind who would even believe a thing
like that could happen and we went 18
months not one american soldier was
killed
i told abdul the head of
the taliban abdul don't do it don't even
think about doing it 18 months we went i
told it much tougher than that but i
don't want to drive people crazy i don't
want to drive the fake dudes crazy
but we set it in a strong tone and we
went 18 months think of it 18 months not
one soldier killed and
when you just thought it couldn't get
worse any worse than that i think that
was frankly the lowest point in the
history of our country in my opinion i
can think of lower points
to deter russia's outrageous invasion of
ukraine
you could take the five worst presidents
in american history and put them
together and they would not have done
the damage joe biden has done in just 13
months
we have a president representing our
country at the most important time in
history who is physically and mentally
challenged
it sounds like he's talking
is
about
himself
atrocity
that should never
have been allowed by the way if people
need mercy bands tonight i would
completely understand it here tonight
when i say we are praying for the proud
people of ukraine they are going through
hell
they are fighters and god blessed them
all
[Applause]
make no mistake however that russia
would not have dared to annex one inch
of territory
if i was in
the white house in fact
[Music]
they never did it didn't they have
people in the donetsk and luhansk the
entire trump presidency and trump said
nothing about it and china
he said they knew better yeah that's
true
yeah so what a nice crowd look at that
crowd up there beautiful
beautiful
in fact i stand
as the only president of the 21st
century on whose watch russia did not
invade another country and neither did
anyone else
they knew that's definitely untrue also
we'll fact check that monday peace
through strength that's what it was our
country was safe and the world was calm
because america was strong
and they respected your leadership
and america was
always a place that i put
and i put it before everybody else it
was always america first very simple
it's very simple
it was all about
america first it was also about make
america great again but it was about
america first because that's how you
make it great
we rebuilt the u.s military with 2.5
trillion dollars that was spent the
largest number ever spent
we had fighter jets that were 40 years
old we had old equipment broken
equipment everything is brand new
beautiful and i hate to do it and i hate
to tell you but our nuclear
weapons i rebuilt them and we have brand
new and i hate to even mention it
because is that true first thing we ever
want
to use is nuclear weapons but nobody has
what we've built and our president
always says but russia is a nuclear
power but so are we he never says that
he never says that and you never want to
use it but the way you don't use it is
by letting everyone know that we have it
bigger and better stronger than they do
we obliterated the senior ranks of al
we decimated isis we got rid of isis 100
we killed al-baghdadi
the head of isis
and we terminated kasim
salamani
[Music]
he was responsible for all of those
bombs that go off in the road and
destroy our people and other people and
blow everybody to pieces losing their
legs and losing their arms and losing
everything they have
he was responsible for that we stood up
to china and iran like never before
china paid us hundreds of billions of
dollars of taxes and tariffs while i was
president before i was president they
never paid us 10 cents and iran was
ready to make a deal
they were done they had
nothing they were ready to make a deal
if the election weren't rigged we would
have had a deal within
two weeks of the election sure we made
it clear that any and the wall was two
weeks from being done guys get clear
that
any
adversary who threatened our people
did so at their own peril
and
interestingly we built such a strong
military we had such great people such
great people you know we have great
generals when i knocked out isis
these speeches are sort of like when at
a wedding
the they're supposed to be three
speeches and some fourth person who's
had too much to drink gets up and
insists on speaking then something
happened 59 missiles shot right down
their throat in syria
and the russians were right next door in
their barracks they
they sort of started running pretty fast
59 missiles you remember that and i was
having dinner with president xi of china
and i said president
i'd like to tell you something what is
it what is it
china all the time through his
interpreter he didn't speak english i
didn't think he spoke
english at all it's a story i think i've
never told a big crowd like this but
i didn't think he spoke english because
he wouldn't even say hello we had a very
good relationship until covet and then i
said forget it go over that was
a step too far but we did we respected
each other
we respected each other but i said
president we're using chocolate cake at
mar-a-lago chocolate beautiful chocolate
cake chocolate cake and they were very
close in some form to syria i said
president later tonight
i want to let you know something uh i
have to tell you not that you go back to
your beautiful room and say
he never even told me that we just shot
59 missiles
into syria
and he said
without his interpreter repeat
how is the cake relevant to this
i didn't think he spoke english
these are very smart people we're
dealing with you know we have somebody
that's not at the top of his game never
was actually
and these people are at the top of their
game
but he said repeat i said you got a
beginning
so he knew everything we were saying so
don't talk behind their back
under my leadership america was feared
by does anybody understand what that
story was about does anybody have any
idea what that anecdote was about
[Applause]
[Music]
you know when i first started in
politics i have to say that they had a
very high
approval rating now they have an
approval rating that's lower than
congress isn't that nice
so we got the point across the fake news
said
my personality would get us into a war
i'm telling you that guy's gonna get us
into a war but actually my personality
is what kept us out of war
[Music]
i was the only president in nearly four
decades who did not get america into any
new conflicts instead i brought our
troops and our wonderful children back
home i brought him back home where they
belong he was just criticizing biden for
getting us out of afghanistan which he
failed to do but now he says i brought
troops home well didn't biden been a
time where our country
has been treated the way it is right now
other countries are lecturing us and
telling us what to do and that's why we
are seeing chaos and mayhem and
bloodshed all over the world
never been a time like it meanwhile you
have warmongers like this crazy liz
cheney she's a nutjob
and adam
adam kinsey you ever see him he gets on
television he cries all the time he
starts crying i don't know governor is
that an actor is he sir republican on
republican stuff is good trust me we
want more of it
adam kinser divides the troops and the
other
neocons who have never found me
that they did not want and by the way we
got everything we wanted we didn't have
to go to war
they don't mind our soldiers and other
people and other soldiers from other
countries dying they don't think about
that in the name of democracy they
destroyed syria libya iraq and
afghanistan i brought our soldiers back
home
leaving a trail of devastation one of my
favorite things are the transitions from
trump riffing to getting back on the
prompter and sometimes it's so jarring
with
ukraine i sent the javelins that you see
are so effective against the tanks
biden didn't and in fact remember he
withheld military aid to ukraine because
he wanted dirt on biden when colonel
vinman outed what was going on trump had
no choice but to release the military
aid now trump wants credit for it they
said
well you know what the javelins are the
anti-tank weapons they knocked the hell
out of those tanks
and ukraine wouldn't be having a chance
without him that was all sent by me all
of it we sent other military equipment
to we didn't send our soldiers but we
sent them a lot of equipment what do you
say before military corpsment he's
really struggling to speak maybe it's
the temperature of our failed foreign
policy establishment it is indeed rotten
to the core before
these total lunatics lead us down the
path of national ruin and world war
three they will do it too
we have to continue to drain the swamp
we did a lot of it but the swamp was
deep deeper than anybody believed
despite all of biden's weakness
cowardice and incompetence there is
still a path for him to end this tragedy
in ukraine without getting america
ensnared in a gruesome and very bloody
war a bloody war this could lead by the
way this could lead to world war iii i
see what's happening right because if
you think putin's going to stop it's
going to get worse and worse he's not
going to accept it and we don't have
anybody to talk to him you had somebody
to talk to him with me nobody was ever
tougher on russia than me i'm the one
that stopped the pipeline i had to stop
i'm the one that put all the sanctions
on
and i'm the one that he didn't attack
during our administration everyone's
asking about that now even the radical
left reporters up there
the u.s must make clear to putin
that he has two choices to negotiate
peace right now or else face blistering
consequences including a push to
permanently eliminate dependence on
russian energy and we're talking about
forever or for a long long time because
without the money coming in from energy
russia doesn't work
but to make this threat credible the u.s
would have to immediately end biden's
ridiculous war on american energy we
were energy independent
now remember even under biden's first
year the u.s produced as much oil as it
used being producing mining and refining
like never before we have to do that
some of them are sitting right back here
hold on it's a nice-looking group you
know they all become famous here's the
thing you have a better location
but they're going to become famous you
know why they're on television
you have a better location but they're
going to become famous so what
[Applause]
because those faces
those beautiful faces these people are
all on television
thank you
[Applause]
child abuse happening
but it is true i i tell you you know
over there we've met a lot of speeches
and we always have the biggest girls by
the way the biggest crowds ever no
politician nobody's ever
you know what honestly elvis doesn't
have guns we breathe there must be 250
000 people at this rally
two weeks ago in texas 87 000. there it
is
there were 6 000 people guys
87 000 they turned away 50 000 people at
the head of the fair an old guy
wonderful guy came up to me said you
know sir i never thought i'd see it what
sir
you broke elvis presley's record sure
sure and i said you know what i said to
him yeah and i didn't have a guitar
it's easy i'm just up here guys
no one in the chat believes there were
87 000 people there right i hope i hope
nobody's in my chat isn't going to
believe that there were there were five
to 8 000 people there
and there'll be somebody in the audience
behind us that's so stunning
that's so handsome or beautiful
handsome or beautiful
that you cannot
take your mind or your eyes off that
person whoa and you know that sometimes
hollywood calls those people
so we've made a lot of really great
stars sitting there we've never made a
star out by the way has anyone become
famous from standing behind trump at a
rally like what's he even talking about
i'm not aware of a single person who's
become famous for that
of the most energy i guess blacks for
trump generally but no one even knows
who those guys are you are right about
that by the way sir
yet because of his party's climate
hysteria what they believe on the
climate biden lock down american oil and
natural gas production
and now biden is crawling around the
globe on his knees begging and pleading
for mercy from saudi arabia iran and
venezuela you know what they don't
understand so
we all want clean air we all want all of
the things that they talk about the
green new deal the woman that thought of
the green new deal didn't even go to
a college to study it she made it up by
the way it was 12 years we're down to
seven
seven years the world is gonna be
destroyed because
the oceans are gonna rise one one
hundredth of an inch within the next 300
years it's gonna kill everybody
it's going to create more oceanfront
property that's what it's going to do
no they say over the next 300 years the
oceans will rise
about this much
but you know the real threat we have is
the nuclear threat that's going to be
the global warming and we can't let that
ever happen the nuclear threat that's
the real global warming that nobody ever
talks about
the lunatics on the left the
global radicals these are global
environmental radicals they never talk
about it to tap into iranian oil
anybody know what that was even about
what's he even talking about signed a
new iran nuclear deal remember i
terminated it because it was so pathetic
he gave them billions i gave them
hundreds of billions of dollars
for nothing
for a bad deal it was a path to nuclear
weapons
and the new deal that they're
negotiating
and you know who's negotiating it
china and russia is representing us
china
china and russia china did you see kerry
the other day on television here we are
everyone's dying for energy your prices
are going up your fuel tanks are costing
you four or five times more and so they
can't get fuel
and he said no this is a good time to be
promoting windmills
this is a good time to be promoting the
green agenda i tell you what your great
governor isn't promoting it he's
promoting inexpensive gasoline for your
cars
inexpensive gasoline
and he's also an environmentalist i have
to tell you henry we love you henry so
is the gas cheaper expensive i don't
even get it
you better not
any republic the noise causes cancer to
that republican okay
nobody's so stupid
he's also selling out the brave people
of cuba and venezuela
groveling at the feet of the oil-rich
and brutal
maduro regime they're after maduro and
now all of a sudden they say listen
forget that forget what we've been
saying for the last long time
and the man the gentleman that preceded
him forget the last 15 years we'd like
to buy oil
and we'll pay you any price you want
please please please sell us some oil
please sell us tomorrow we don't have
any oil
he must think we are the stupidest
people he's not having a stroke is he
but it's very heavy you got to put it
through the ringer to get oil out of it
we have the best oil in the world that's
sitting right i call it liquid gold and
we don't want to take it from us you
know it's a big advantage we have over
china we have oil they don't we have
natural gas they don't we have coal they
don't
the entire world is laughing at the
united states this is to be the most
pathetic spectacle that
anyone's seen nobody's ever seen
anything like that and elon musk who's a
guy that i like and respect friend of
mine he runs an electric car company
he's calling for biden to increase oil
and gas production
but biden won't do it because he does
not have the will to stand up to aoc
you know arc we call aoc
[Applause]
i don't think she ever took a course on
the environment and now she said we got
12 years i mean did trump
i call it aoc plus three you ever see
your people omar
the group aoc plus three
and the radical left under my
administration
we had a very different energy policy
america energy independence and america
energy dominance we were dominant we
were dominant think of it a year and a
half ago we were dominant
the good news is i used to say
four years is a long time now we're down
to two and a half years we have a big
election coming up in just a matter of
months it's incredible
i approve the keystone xl and dakota
access pipelines i withdrew from the one
side in paris at least he's making good
time through the prompter stuff i'm glad
i have to tell you i'm pleased about
that clean power plan sounds great
except it's a disaster and very
expensive for our country doesn't do
anything we unlock the vast lands for
energy development
we opened edward you know what anwar is
the biggest site anywhere in the world
for drilling oh my god
anwar i thought he said he opened the
n-word
anwar i tried to get it approved i got
it done and in one day
biden had it wiped out this is in alaska
lisa murkowski did a horrible job for
the people lisa
makowsky guys guys
lisa
mikowski
but lisa mikowski is actually not that
bad lisa murkowski
but we had anwar approved probably the
biggest drilling site anywhere in the
world energy jobs everything great for
alaska and for our country
and they ended it very quickly and one
day and one day it was gone the united
states became but we'll get it back okay
we're going to get that back okay we're
going to get it back we're going to get
it back quickly the united states became
the world's number one energy superpower
we were doing a job like nobody's ever
done before a net exporter of energy for
the first time in 72 years
you know the strategic
uh i don't know if you know federal
reserves do you know what it's about
where we're dumping
it's not the strategic federal reserve
it's the strategic petroleum reserve
when we had the energy low
oh there's my friend she's so great
she's been with me right from the
beginning you take your time chris you
take your time
that's bikers for trump does everyone
know chris spiker
when chris is there you're safe ma'am
but she's been our supporter for a long
time we love her and thank you very much
thank you chris
thank you chris you know uh the bikers i
don't know what it is with bikers but i
think i had a hundred percent of their
vote and you know pretty much the same
for law enforcement the military pretty
much
but
when i'd go to like
i'd go to places in south carolina and
north carolina and all over the place
i'd say
i feel very safe we'd have sometimes two
thousand three thousand bikers
and secret service and all the law
enforcement that said sir i don't know
if you're safe here i say i'm the safest
guy in the world right here yeah sure
and then rev up those harleys
and the girlfriends on the back they
loved that sucker
they loved it
they loved it any guy went after
that guy's girlfriend did number one
didn't have a chance number two he would
have been in big trouble right
he would have been in big trouble but
they were great the bikers for trump we
love them anybody know what this is
about
they are tremendous people you know
they're really patriots they love our
country the biden energy crisis
and the ukraine crisis you know what
i've noticed
trump hates it when it's cold and it's
pretty cold there
i think that's why he's rushing through
the speech he doesn't want to be out
there
it's time to stop the bloodshed in our
own cities look at what's going on in
chicago and new york and los angeles and
portland i mean portland they've taken
over the
the place the whole it's ridiculous
what's going on in portland but many
other
all democrat-run
cities all of them all of them
you see some of these stats in chicago
where eight people were shot this
weekend and four died
and many more than that and many worse
sets than that obviously that's terrible
but this idea that it's because
democrats run cities has been so widely
debunked democrats run safe cities and
dangerous cities democrats tend to run
cities because democrats live in cities
it's time to secure our own elections
it's time to by the way
it took me two and a half years to get
through all of the litigation and
lawsuits on the border wall and i won i
won 11 cases and we won other
and we had it done
three weeks away from finishing it then
we had a election result that everybody
or most people know was a fake they
built 90 miles of wall in 11 in three
years and 11 months
and in that last couple weeks they were
going to finish the entire wall
immediately and that's when i knew that
they actually wanted open borders when
they didn't want to go that extra three
weeks to finish the wall but it had a
tremendous impact we had the safest
border in the history of our country
one year ago and today we have the worst
border in the history of our country
so it's time to save our own nation from
the people who are trying to destroy it
under biden pelosi and the radical
democrats we're losing our country no
different than if we had lost it in a
war
if we had lost it at a war you know we
have
hundreds of thousands of people
dying to drugs that come over the
southern border now
we did a tremendous job on the southern
border we had the best numbers we've
ever had and we've had the best drug
numbers we stopped drugs at a level that
nobody had ever seen before
and now they're coming in at a level
that nobody has ever seen when you have
open borders nobody's very little has
changed in terms of the border illegal
aliens are rushing across our borders
from all over the world criminals gang
members drug traffickers human smugglers
and people on terrorist watch list are
stampeding
right into our country the biden
administration has spent months and
months obsessing over how to stop an
invasion of a foreign country
i believe americans deserve a president
who will stop the invasion into our
country
and for all the talk about violent
conflict in eastern europe and it's a
terrible thing and we're gonna help and
we're gonna do whatever we can because
nobody can look at the bloodshed much
longer what's happening it's a lack of
respect
for a lot of people a lot of things but
it's just a total lack of respect
and it happens to be a man that is just
driven he's driven to put it together
and you look at it and it's just so
ridiculous and so senseless and so
horrible it's driven it's it's being
done by a man who's driven to put it
together
what does that mean what is that what
exactly does that mean but no one ever
mentions the bloody and horrific war
raging
just across our border they don't
mention that the drug wars have killed
hundreds of thousands of people
throughout latin america and hundreds of
thousands of people in our country
mexico
innocent
people
murdering judges and journalists
torturing and slaughtering hostages and
burying victims in mass graves mass
graves
now joe biden has thrown the gates open
to these murderous cartels and thugs and
bloodthirsty criminal gangs to flood
into our country every day the radical
democrats
anybody know when biden did that
i don't remember that king's killed we
have brandon judd here he's an
incredible guy and tom allman who's an
incredible tom home in his central
casting that's the kind of guy they
don't want to see they don't want to see
brendan judd where's brandon judd
what a job he does head of border patrol
what a job you do
and your people at ice are incredible
these are brilliant brave patriots i
wouldn't want their job brandon i
wouldn't want your job you know ice will
go into a pack ms-13 probably the worst
gangs are ms-13 but ice will go up to
them they break into our country
and they'll charge them they kill people
they like using knives rather than guns
because it's more painful
did you guys understand a word of that
ice will go up to them
they'll charge them because they they
enter our country what dump them the
hell out of our country and the other
countries from where they came they now
take them they didn't used to take them
i said why aren't they taking them they
said sir they just won't take them back
they don't want them to take them back i
said how much money does the united
states give to those countries sure and
they said i don't know sir about 742
million
okay stop it as of now we give them no
money the next day i got a call from the
president of those countries sir we'd
love to have our members of ms-13 back
in our country
it took about two minutes but this was
going on for years they wouldn't take
them back now they take them back but i
think that's going to be lost probably
probably by now brandon that's gone down
the tubes just like everything else has
gone down the tubes just last month an
illegal alien criminal was arrested in
california
california for horribly assaulting an
officer cowell lafornia his deadly
sanctuary state law the vicious criminal
was released back into the community
just five days later he walked into a
church and savagely murdered his 9 10
and 13 year old daughters and other
people that happen to be in the church
we have dozens of countries emptying out
their prisons into america we're like a
there is not a single country emptying
their prisons into america
not to mention
we imprison more people than anybody
else most the prisoners are here already
bum rushed the plane
and 97 of those people should not have
been brought into our country we're
going to be paying a big price
from what we took out and from the
people that pour into our country for
many years to come you watched and i
made a lot of good predictions and now
saying trump was right i was right on
the border i was right on the pipeline
i was right on germany i said to angela
merkel i said angela i'm sending you the
white flag
she said but why are you sending me the
white flag i said it's called the
flag of surrender
because you're getting your energy from
russia
and it's not good now nobody knew it
would happen this quickly but who would
have thought to think that i shut the
pipeline down now we're getting into
what i call the doldrums of the trump
speech which it's in the middle at first
the crowd's all excited to see him
and then later he starts the wind-up
crescendo to close the middle is where
the crowd has no idea what he's talking
about sometimes they're physically
uncomfortable because they've been
standing there for hours and the crowd
tends to go dead right now
hearing now true now on chaos if you
want crime if you want carnage you must
immediately vote for radical democrats
because they will give it to you that's
what they're doing
look at every city that's run by the
democrats if you want
safety
security and strength vote for america
first republicans this november
but before we can defeat the democrats
socialists and communists at the ballot
boxes fall
we first have to defeat the rhinos and
grandstanders in the primaries earlier
this year
the rhinos those rhinos are no good
i don't just as a quick fact check just
to fact check something there's so many
lies it's hard to some of the safest
cities in america are run by democrats
including irvine california sunnyvale
fremont
yeah naperville illinois uh
bellevue washington uh on and on and on
i know is there bad people in the house
who went to washington
sold you out and partnered with the
democrats to stab the republican party
and frankly to stab our country in the
back
right here in the seventh congressional
district tom rice a disaster
[Applause]
[Music]
he's respected by no one he's laughed at
in washington he was never thought
highly of in washington
and he was just censored by your great
south carolina gop
tom rice joined the democrats deranged
impeachment witch hunt hoax it's all
turned out to be a hoax it's all turned
out now to be a hoax he parroted their
lies he gave aid and comfort to their
weaponization of the national security
state
against the domestic political opponents
he voted for the unselect committee
of highly
partisan politicians that are running
this horrible witch hunt in washington
it's a witch hunt like nobody is this is
where the audience is mostly tuned out
the last 15 minutes have been the
doldrums occasional signs of life from
the audience and i do think i see i see
black voices i guess that's different
than blacks for trump said i didn't know
what i voted to impeach president trump
i was committing political suicide and
you know that's exactly what happened
and hopefully it'll be true
in the first congressional district you
have another horrendous rhino known as
crazy nancy mace
two years ago she begged for my
endorsement and i pledged
and she pledged
to be america first all the way she's
going to be i'm going to be america
first instead the first thing nancy mace
did when she got to washington was start
attacking
republicans and hold a fundraiser for
wacky liz cheney
liz cheney who's polling now at 12
in the great state of wyoming
i think she's pretty popular in wyoming
still anyone know that i got number one
state was wyoming in terms of uh the
vote i hate to tell you south carolina
but i did damn well with you two
and alabama
you know what's sort of interesting
we won south carolina in a record we won
alabama in a record
but we lost georgia just by a whisker
does it happen that way
it doesn't happen when you win alabama
henry
i see liz cheney polling uh 64 as of uh
today also henry
jd joined the phony narrative about
january 6. she voted to hold steve
bannon in contempt which was terrible
she's totally manipulated by raging
never trumpers and the radical left
democrats that are poisoning our country
she's a terrible person and she has no
idea what she's doing nancy mace right
after hearing i was going to endorse a
really wonderful person a different
candidate
she went to new york and stood in front
of the magnificent trump tower has
anyone ever heard of trump tower
and did a commercial
insinuating that i was endorsing her
she's standing or in front of trump
tower in new york i'm saying can you
believe this
it was untruthful just like everything
else she does thankfully
this june you have the chance to dump
these grandstanding losers and replace
them with two rocks
america first champions russell frye
russell where's russell russell frye
and katie arrington where are you come
on up come come here we go
russell is a conservative i know it's
hard to tell because he's talking all
about himself mostly but this is
actually supposed to be a rally to
promote people he's endorsing the
fighter for the people of south carolina
and you know
a few years ago she beat mr argentina do
you know who that is
he liked that argentina dancer remember
you remember that mr argentina
but katie uh you know she went through a
lot because she was she did a fantastic
rant of fantastic race and she was
horribly horribly injured in an
automobile accident and she never had
the chance to uh
campaign and it was just incredible
because she was incredible and but she
was so badly injured and now she's a
hundred percent but that was a that was
a tough time yeah
that was a tough that was a tough period
of time but she's been fantastic and
she's been loyal and she loves
the people of south carolina the people
of our country they will be tough on
crime
strong on borders strong on election
integrity and they will support our
military and our vets and they will
never
appease the fake news or the radical
left
so i want to ask everybody in this
incredible state i love this state
i want them to have the same kind of
i want them to have the same kind of
vote that you gave me to get out and
vote for russell frye and katie
arrington in the primary on june 14th
which is my birthday
that's my birthday
that's flag day so that's a big day
so i know you spoke before but why don't
you just say two words and uh we'll uh
then get the hell out of here cause it's
called don't take away too much time
from trump please
[Applause]
it's like i said earlier
[Music]
on june 14th it's our turn to vote and
on june 14th here in the seventh
congressional district we're gonna vote
to impeach tom rice at the ballot box
yes you can sure
i always have to bring them a stool
so you know i have a name for nancy mary
so i call her liz cheney of the south
you like that it's all for you good guy
it's true it's true
everybody i think we all deserve to give
this gentleman behind me djt one hell of
a round of applause
this woman's dangerous she could
potentially be like another bo bear
marjorie taylor green your name
is you're the best damn president this
country's ever had
period end of story
very sick woman any better
be our number 47
you were our 46 br 47 that's all i got
to say thank you
[Music]
wow
very sick woman
in 2020
120 of the 122 candidates that i
endorsed in congressional primary
elections won their election okay so
here's the deal on trump's record
he's about
55
of the time choosing winners
and he chooses a lot of incumbents so
his record's not so good couple of
primaries
there are a couple of continuing
primaries but they're going to win their
way ahead they're going to win
so we view it as 33 out of 33 and i just
got
approval trump's opinion is he's 100
that's the best that's pretty good
so we got to get out and vote for those
two we got to put nancy mace and we got
to put tom rice back where they came
from
we're also joined by other great
republican leaders tonight
including your incredible governor and
my friend he was so loyal to me i said
boy this guy's incredible and his
unbelievable wife
mr and mrs
henry mcmaster governor mcmaster
congratulations henry thank you thank
you both thank you for being here
congratulations freezing cold thank you
peggy very much great job boy they
became great friends
remember i had the lieutenant governor
other people had the governor and the
lieutenant governor won so thank you
very much we'll never forget it henry
also with us our lieutenant governor
pamela yvette thank you
thank you pamela thank you very much
attorney general
alan wilson great family alan
thank you alan
former ambassador woody johnson and his
incredible family suzanne and woody i
don't know where the hell you are but
you're in hello mike there's a many the
greatest buyer events in history michael
thank you mike there's pillow
thank you mike
and a great patriot
former ambassador a man who loves south
carolina a lot ed mcmullan
did a great job representatives joe
wilson and carol miller
state house speaker jay lucas
is that the same joe wilson who yelled
you lie at obama during uh a state of
the union yeah drew mckissaco we love
drew
president of the national border patrol
brandon judd i just introduced him
one of the most popular men in america
great coach everybody wanted him to get
the presidential medal i always
fantasize that someone just slips trump
names and he doesn't know what they are
and he'll go uh local mayor uh jack
mayhoffer here thank you jack breakers
for trump and bikers for every
[Music]
bikers period just bikers
with the help of everyone here tonight
republicans are going to take back
control of congress and then we must
quickly put our big and bold agenda into
action
one of the most important lessons
of the past two years is that to be a
strong nation america must also be a
manufacturing nation we have to bring
back our emmanuel remember biden said
the same thing at the state of the union
or any other country
to give us our critical products
and we cannot have our vital supply
chains whoever heard of this you can't
get anything
the stores are half empty we have a
supply chain nobody ever even talked
about this and this all came out of the
stench of the biden administration
stretches all over the globe under a
republican congress we should pass
historic legislation and powerful
tariffs to bring our essential
industries back home to america and back
to south carolina yeah biden said the
exact same thing and they never explain
how to do it and they never explain how
consumers will be able to afford what
stuff will cost if you do it terminating
every last federal covet mandate
convalescence and on day one we should
force the pentagon to rehire all the
great service members biden forced out
of the military with his lawless vaccine
mandates
with an apology and all back pay
in addition a republican congress must
stand up for parental rights and
parental power
america's moms and dads should get a
veto over everyone and anything teaching
far left gender
ideologies to their children without
parental consent
and we should move quickly to pass the
republican bill to protect women's
sports
women's sports are under attack guys
they're the victims coming 38 seconds
you know is it a record that stood for
11 years did break it by maybe one one
hundredth of a second
he broke it by 38 seconds
the best though are the weightlifting
records you know with one hand boom the
record's broken it's ridiculous
keep men out of women's sports and we
will ban
men
as president i was proud to issue the
world's first ban on critical race
theory in september of 2020 joe biden
rescinded that order but as soon as we
retake congress republicans will ban
critical race theory once and for all
no they won't
they will education
you guys all know education policy is
not set by the house of representatives
right i hope people know that
discrimination in anything
getting critical race theory out of our
schools is not just a matter of values
it's also a matter of national survival
we have no choice the fate of any nation
ultimately depends upon the willingness
of its citizens to lay down and they
must do this lay down their very lives
to defend their country if we allow the
marxists and communists and socialists
to teach our children to hate america
there will be no one left to defend our
flag or to protect our great country or
its freedom
2022 is the year that trump has really
played up the transphobia country was
invaded like ukraine was invaded a
majority of democrats stunningly
admitted that they would not fight for
america
[Music]
for the same reason
we have to get political correctness out
of our military
the woke generals
should be fired the military now is
politically correct and woke can you can
you imagine about winning wars not to
teach pronouns
it's all so far past time for
big tech and to restore look at what big
tech is doing how dishonest they are how
dishonest and corrupt they are so they
are horrible for our country we have to
restore free speech in our country and
we will
yeah nobody can speak anymore
google and youtube censored my podcast
with the milk boys
after it was watched by millions and
millions of people a record they
censored my
24 hours they took it down because i
told the truth these are sick people we
have to have in our country freedom of
speech we have to have freedom of speech
if we did a podcast with the milk boys
and made some aggressive comments about
whole milk
and finally at all costs we must defend
the sacred integrity of our elections
just last week
the special counsel investigating the
2020 election wisconsin
the state of wisconsin a highly
respected former state supreme court
justice a great gentleman
announced that 8.8 million dollars mark
zuckerberg poured into local elections
quote facially violates the wisconsin
law prohibiting election bribery that's
a pretty big charge but actually
the investigation revealed that 91
nursing i was thinking that 91 is that a
legal term i'm not familiar with it
facially violates voter turnout rates of
almost 100 even though many of them were
very ill that's a lie some were dying
their families said
my mother never voted
this was just a disgrace what took place
in wisconsin and it was a bombshell in
wisconsin in addition to the explosive
evidence gathered by true the vote you
all know none of these claims are true
right like in some places they say more
people voted than there are voters no
that didn't happen anywhere and
thousands of ballot traffickers they're
known as mules they go in they carry
ballots every day there is more
overwhelming evidence that the 2020
election and by the way it's even beyond
the standpoint of evidence there is so
much fact it was corrupt it was
fraudulent and loaded up with
irregularities one of the wettest we've
ever seen from the standpoint of water
so i ran twice
i won twice
and i did much better the second time
that we did the first
getting 12 million more votes and now we
may have to run again
they may do
it and god bless
the united church
at the federal state and local level
republicans must act to ensure universal
voter id
citizenship confirmation no more drop
boxes no more private money pay for
so-called help with the elections
and we must ensure that every election
can be fully and quickly audited
will he call for a lawsuit against all
machines like mike pillow same-day
elections
with mail-in ballots only for the
military and vote for those people who
are very ill and cannot vote in person
same-day elections i guess like trump
because he voted by mail so our sittings
around
they sit around in storage areas for 20
30 40 days henry
because lots of bad things are happening
to them as security guards are not doing
their job our election was rigged and we
can never let this happen again and we
will continue to go forward but we will
also never ever forget what happened and
we continue to look at the fraud and
things are happening on a daily basis
like nobody would believe it was a
fraudulent election and the proof is
beyond anybody's wildest
expectation
we are just eight months away from what
could be the most important midterm
election if anybody's wondering why
trump's speaking so quickly it's because
he's cold and when he's cold the
speeches are much shorter at the radical
democrats cannot rig or steal the
elections
very much like the landslide we had
nice swing you have scorned
are you a golfer what's your handicap
huh that's a nice looking swing i'm
proud of
you very much like the landslide that we
had in your state in south carolina very
much
so to every patriot here today i ask you
to get ready to work get ready to fight
get ready to win
and we're gonna win like never before
we're going to win like never before
when what is the year we are going to
take back the house we are going to take
back the senate and we are going to take
back america and in 2024
we are going to take back that beautiful
beautiful white house
i wonder who will do that i wonder i
wonder
together with your help we will fight
for more jobs for american families fair
trade for american workers and more
south carolina factories forging more
products stamped with that beautiful
phrase made in the usa
okay we will shut down joe biden's board
of disaster we will again then catch and
release we will
end chain migration and we will end visa
lottery and we will get that wall
finished so fast your head will spin
we will hold china accountable for
unleashing the virus and charge them
trillions of dollars for the damage and
suffering they have caused
we will stop the biden crime wave in our
democrat-run cities we will crack down
on violent criminals and we will give
our police office as our law enforcement
we love them our 100
support we will pass critical reforms
making every executive branch employee
fireable
viable by the president of the united
states the deep state must and will be
brought to heal it's already happening
we will protect openly just promoting
conspiracy theories now
and we will defend the second amendment
we will proudly upheld the
judeo-christian values and principles of
our nation's founding
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools we will teach the guy who
claims he's for small government wants
to add a whole bunch of people to the
list that the president can fire
our great american flag
and in conclusion our maga movement is
by conclusion the greatest political
movement in the history of our country
together we are standing up against some
of the most sinister forces and
certainly the dumbest political movement
vicious opponents
our people have ever seen
but no matter how big or powerful these
corrupt radicals may be
you must never forget this nation does
not belong to them
this nation belongs to you
this is your home
this is your heritage
and our imagine hearing this and being
inspired you know that's that's part of
the problem that people do like some
people like this stuff patriots like you
who built this country
and it's patriots like you who are going
to save our country this is a very very
critical time
our country has never been in trouble
like it is right now
in a little more than a year they have
gone on to almost destroy
our country but the key word is almost
we're not going to let it happen
and together we will make a more
exceptional
country than ever before
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no summit we cannot reach
there is no challenge we cannot meet
there is no vic if you want to talk
about the framers if you ever told them
that a guy like this would hold the
attention of a significant portion of
america's voters as anything other than
a charlatan con man the founders would
have been
extraordinarily disturbed flinching
courage is
coursing through our veins so beautiful
beautiful
blood
red white and blue
we will not bend
we will not break
we will not yield we will never give in
we will never give up we will never ever
back down
as long as we are confident and united
the tyrants we are fighting do not stand
a chance of winning
because we are americans and americans
kneel to god
and kneel to god alone
wow my fellow citizens this incredible
journey we are on together has only just
begun and it is time to start talking
about greatness for our country again
our country will be great again
we are one movement we are one people
one family and one glorious american
nation under god
together we are unstoppable together we
are unbeatable what a long conclusion
huh ultimate victory is inevitable
and so with the help of everyone here
today and it's such an honor to be with
you even though we're all very cold out
here
and with the commitment of hard-working
freedom-loving patriots across this
magnificent land
we will
make america powerful again
we will make america wealthy again we
will make america strong again
we will make america proud again
we will make america
safe again
and we will make america great again
god bless you thank you south carolina
we love you thank you
so there it is
[Music]
all right sam and dave soul man there
you go yeah quite a day huh
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean really the sad commentary is the
fact that people still like this stuff
and at at minimum tens of millions would
vote for it again that's really scary
that should scare all of us
uh super chat's pouring in larry just
saying yes
uh
most of what trump said
you could find the truth just by
believing the opposite
it's really quite that simple
[Music]
sir
there goes sir
[Music]
so definitely a delusional speech that's
not new
but
very very much now
at least alluding to i'm gonna run again
and i i do think he will run again
unless there are signs that he has no
shot
or unless his health doesn't allow it
if his health doesn't allow it then i
think that would certainly prevent him
from running in 2024
by the way the people that he endorsed
here
are dangerous lunatic extremists and
we'll talk about some of them next week
on the show as well
i would love to hear trump explain what
critical race theory is yeah i mean
obviously he has no idea
i think he would say something like it
teaches white people that they're bad or
something like that
[Music]
will you hurt
well thank you for joining me everybody
it's been another
pretty depressing night because if it
were just trump doing like a comedy act
it would be one thing but there's people
who would vote for this again
and that is a really really scary thing
danny says sir the only reason i can
watch these is with you and the other
members thank you danny
larry says sir much love for the streams
the only way this stuff is digestible
thank you larry
richard says david how are you able to
watch the pandering fascist rhetoric and
keep keep your cool i'm seething
uh i um i i took xanax before the stream
that's how that's a joke by the way oh
by the way i get peop sometimes people
write to me and they go david
um
i don't want to make a big deal out of
this but it's very obvious that you're
drinking now when you do your show
and i just want to see you know the
other day david i can tell you you've
you've lost a lot of weight and i i'm
actually the exact same my weight has
not changed at all
um
so anyway i did not take any xanax just
to be clear brian says thank you for
your strong stance against russian
imperialism
jason says can you give a shout out to
my wife claire we love your show claire
welcome and please
do not ban do not ban jason from your
home and we will ban men exactly we
don't want to see that at all
the camera adds 10 drinks exactly right
no in all seriousness it's dinner time
i've got some beautiful chirashi waiting
for me so i will bid you a dew and i
will be back with you this week for more
streaming more clips
more everything more everything see
everybody very soon